good morning John I'm in your home it's
the pizza John All-Stars everybody
that's how embarrassing we're wearing
the same outfit look at the detail
quality our world needs to increase
Access to Health Care like in Sierra
Leone where all of the proceeds from
Pizza the sales are going Lauren says
that this is the tiniest statue in the
world it's only available for the next
couple days what are we doing today well
John I put pizza John into an AI art
generator and then I just absolutely
lost my mind and I want to walk you
through the process that I went through
great without all of the trial and error
this was pizza John okay put in this
what do you think what's your first
reaction it's devastating when an AI
thinks about a pizza person the AI
thinks Pizza person because AIS only
have nightmares so then I put in uh
Pizza John Vector which was a little bit
better and it did get that you have
glasses and a mustache
to be fair a better mustache this uh was
later when I put in Pizza John mustache
glasses wow it's actually quite nice I
might buy that as a t-shirt which is the
problem is a little concerning to me
it's just stealing from what people have
created right it's just getting very
good at it for example from here I was
like I need more and so I typed in Pizza
John Green by Van Gogh it made me look a
little bit like Van Gogh which I'm
alarmed by it was like oh and then I
like the fact that it it doesn't show
one of my ears that was a bold Choice
John Green the author made entirely of
pizza it's like a pizza quilt it's like
like they made a quilt that has I like
this one a lot the AI really wants me to
be handsome yeah I for one appreciate it
John Green wearing a pizza as a hat a
Renaissance painting the pizza looks
vaguely quilted it's like the AI has
never actually eaten a pizza and doesn't
know what makes a pizza pizza John Green
Pizza art Andy Warhol I I don't think it
looks like Andy Warhol but I do think
it's actually pretty cool I thought that
this one did too good of a job of
actually capturing the Eunice of you it
looks too much like me I needed to
depart and so I did John Green pizza boy
drippy cheese with glasses which I liked
a lot but it doesn't look like you at
all I tried to Reign it back in and just
did pizza John again oh no and then I
lost my mind oh God this one is John
Green's face inside a pizza hyper
realistic creepy Vibe so I was leaning
into it I can't believe they gave me
spirals For Eyes I've always felt like I
have spirals For Eyes how do they know
that all of those ingredients on the
pizza are like little animals and eyes
so then I said John Green as a pizza
monster just absolutely terrible worst
thing ever but still John Green and I
think it got it spot on it's a little
bit Salvador Dali yeah but with more
Shrek so then I had John good made of
pizza wearing a crown color pencil
illustration I like that they made the
crown out of pizza yeah and I like that
I have two noses again yeah your nose is
a nose well when you really love pizza
you want to be able to smell it twice so
then oh I went with John Green Pizza
propaganda poster they're great and that
made me think I need to do more words so
here are some pizza John restaurant
signs joints they're there's the pies of
the pizza Johns with your proprietor
John's mucus pooters
[Laughter]
Under New Management and then the
culmination of everything I did during
this madness is
[Applause]
from now on I only refer to restaurants
because when I'm in one it's not a
restaurant it's not a restaurant
I also love that it's like his even is
Joe had a toy toy like as a way of
saying like this is a home of eating for
you Pizza John's join iron we're gonna
go do a uh show now yeah and I have to
edit this video and upload it yeah it's
like the old days it's like the oldest a
lot of pressure I'll see you right now
all right Miss Hank's not gonna say it
so I willpizzamist.com pizza.com